this is now completely beyond parody
my pillow ceo and founder mike lindell
i know you're gonna say david but you
did this story last year i know
mike lindell also known as mike pillow
or just pillow
has new
very
very big not just very big but very very
big
cyber evidence
cyber evidence that is going to blow the
roof off
of the 2020 election now we're only what
three and a half months from the 2022
election but he's still working on 2020.
listen to this and at this point does
anyone believe this i mean the crowds at
trump rallies cheer
when he says this stuff but do they even
believe it i got news this morning that
there was uh
very
big big big
big everybody pieces of evidence
cyber
evidence from the 2020 election
that we didn't even know before that now
we have it's it's
i'm just like
so excited validated validated
uh multiple sources and we also found
from another source a completely
different cyber guy um
he seems almost bored by his own
blockbuster news he sounds kind of like
he's over it he found uh
more evidence from the
the uh mesa um
data which we have right up here in
frank's speech so all you horrible
journalists out there that are watching
tonight uh you might want to take a look
there
and uh
look at what i'm talking about and uh
get your cyber guys ready there's more
to come and uh and it's very readable
and understandable a sniffing disheveled
uncomfortable looking mic pillow
making declarations that even his
co-host seems to be pretty damn
skeptical of now would it be shocking to
you to find out that all of this new
evidence
comes from nest thermostats that would
be a big shock but apparently nest
thermostats are the new nexus of cyber
criminality i'm genuinely curious about
how long this is going to go because
we're almost at the 2022 midterms could
pillow keep going with this beyond the
2022 midterms what about 2024 like
there's no way that after 24
he would say we're going to go back and
res reinstate trump from the 2020
election right like that that seems
beyond even
pillows ability to take himself
seriously i don't know the answer but
he's still invited to the trump rallies
he still speaks there and at some point
the question has to become
he keeps if he keeps repeating it
is it because people keep believing it
and thinking that this guy knows
something when he knows nothing at all
maybe like with trump it's more about
the followers than the person saying the
stuff strange
bizarre
unusual and also comical quite frankly
but the the perfect touch here
is that he just seems bored he's like i
have very very big evidence it's coming
out soon
this is like the biggest most exciting
thing
and we're going to tell you it's from uh
you know it's from arizona and it's
gonna just blow everything up it's gonna
overturn the election he he couldn't be
more bored with his own so-called data
all right the question i have is how
long will this go on will it go on
beyond 2022 will it get all the way to
2024 when will pillow end this madness
find me on twitter at dpakman and let me
know
i'm really excited that one of our
sponsors today is helix sleep i sleep on
a helix mattress at home i absolutely
love it and that's why i reached out to
them about sponsoring the david pakman
show
buying a mattress in the past
was always a huge guessing game for me i
didn't know what i actually needed i
didn't know what i would like but helix
has a sleep quiz on their website you
tell them your body type your sleeping
position your back pain issues you might
have and their tool matched me with a
mattress that is perfect for me it's
cool enough at night it's the right
firmness i generally just do way better
sleeping these days because of the
mattress helix was awarded number one
best overall mattress for the last two
years by both gq and wired magazine it
is well deserved i can tell you
firsthand every helix mattress comes
with a 10 year warranty
you can try the mattress risk free for
100 nights and they will even come pick
it up at your house if you don't love it
but i know you will for a limited time
helix is offering up to three hundred
and fifty dollars off all mattress
orders plus two free pillows at
helixsleep.com
pacman it's the biggest discount they've
ever offered the link is down below